today we're playing a ping pong card
game each suit represents a different
shot
and the number decides the amount first
one four points
wins okay i'm a
bigger quark let's see
oh okay nine edge for the edge guy
[Music]
almost missed the first one already
yeah that seems to be easy
[Music]
you would think the high ones are easy
but no
no oh
[Applause]
what are you hoping for are on the nets
of course why am i even asking you
let's see oh
jack i'm pretty sure you won't get this
one i have a feeling you're gonna
make me move now
so far so good
five six good
[Music]
well done it was actually nice to see
you moving there around quite fast yeah
yeah yeah i've been practicing my
footwork going to the fridge
around the nets where are they and
they're there they are
one two there we have it
get one from there
three three eight shots i'm gonna put in
some difficult places
oh one more nice one thanks
oh joe you get to choose you get to
choose the shot
and the amount of shots yes chops
chops chops one chop one chop
ah yes
come on yes now i'm so happy
[Music]
one
[Music]
three four
five six oh that's not
bad
what are you saying we are already
halfway how is it feeling
good so far good but still can't get too
comfortable
two more oh
almost a miss
that's it eleven good one author oh
thank you
that's him behind the back seven
[Music]
two okay this is not gonna go
i already knew from the second shot was
it promising
one or fourteen you get to chew yourself
though but it's if you choose just one
it has to be an around the net so it has
to be around internet yes okay
[Music]
yes we have it oh okay
[Music]
oh you get this before
shouldn't be that big of a problem okay
okay come on
oh on the gopro gopro and the camera
oh one more yes yes we have it
there we have it i need to find our
internet i'll use my
layer solution oh
okay scroll back
let's go back
[Music]
chops chops what the what have you
chosen
360 no look eyes closed behind the back
clean the leg wrong-handed ben holt our
internet from
under the table i regret saying anything
i have a strong feeling that he's not
gonna make this shot
i'm quite interested to see how this
looks
yeah i heard something i think that was
perfect yeah
okay between the legs six of those
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nice doing some good footwork here
it feels like i need to move again
let's let's start it easy off and then
make him
make him move a bit more let's still put
some easy ones
good and now let's do the hard ones
i think that that doesn't count anymore
yeah i knew it was gonna be like that
what's that there's no gentleman rule
anymore
well this was a fun and interesting game
something you guys can also try at phone
yeah and remember to subscribe here and
watch the previous episodes
there until next time